We're speaking today with Heidi
Shierholz, the chief economist
at the US Department of Labor.
Heidi follows the job trends
and occupational opportunities
around the country.
And so this is a
good opportunity
to discuss where some
of the good jobs are.
So Heidi, thank you
for joining us today.
It's my pleasure.
I wonder if you could
start by telling
us what do you see as
some of the good job
opportunities for young people
entering the labor force today?
I think it's important
to know that there
are a lot of good
jobs being created.
There are a lot of
good opportunities.
And if you look, our
Bureau of Labor Statistics
does these employment
projections,
where you can look and
see what kind of jobs
are growing strongly
for the next 10 years,
what kind of wages
will those jobs have.
And there's some
trends that come out
of that, that you can see.
So some of the
fastest growing jobs
are jobs in the health
sector, particularly nurses--
really strong wages and
really strong job growth.
We also see good job
growth in the tech sector,
so software engineering,
software development,
those kinds of jobs
are growing quickly.
You also see projected
growth in some jobs
in professional and
business services
like accountant jobs
and auditing jobs,
sort of those old standbys.
We're going to always need
them, and they're really
decent paying jobs.
So that's at the high
end of the labor force.
How about at the middle
tier of the labor force.
What's happening there?
One of the phenomenons
that we're seeing there
is there's this
big group of people
who are hitting retirement
age, the baby boomers.
And as that continues
to happen, there's
going to be a lot of
job turnover in some
of these really good
middle class jobs
like carpenter jobs, electrician
jobs, utility workers, welders.
Those kinds of jobs
that historically people
got a lot of training
in those kind of jobs
through their unions and
apprenticeship programs.
As we have this
group of people that
was trained in that way
hitting retirement age,
we have to really
figure out how we're
going to refill those jobs.
One of the things the
Department of Labor is doing
is really doing everything we
can to support apprenticeship
programs so they can
help train up people
to get into those jobs,
because those are really
good middle class jobs that
are going to be very in demand
going forward.
Well that's great,
because apprenticeships
have such a positive
record, so rebuilding those
is so critical to our economy
and the future workforce.
Research shows apprenticeship
has the highest rate of return
as far as investment in workers,
what pays off for the economy,
for their future earnings.
So it's a really good
route for our country
to invest in and for people to
take advantage of as they're
thinking about what
their careers are going
to look like going forward.
And what about at
the lower end of
the occupational distribution?
The projections show
that we are expected
to add a lot of jobs
that, at this point,
are low wage jobs: home
health aides, food prep
workers in restaurants and bars,
child care workers, janitors,
maids and housekeeping cleaners.
So some of these
lower end jobs are
projected to see strong
growth going forward.
So I think that's a really
important segment of the labor
market to think about.
And that's where
policy can come in
to help make sure that
those are better jobs.
So things like making sure we
have a decent minimum wage--
increasing the minimum wage.
Making sure people have
overtime protections.
Making sure that
people have paid leave.
The president just
announced initiatives
to bolster paid leave
in the United States.
Those kinds of policies
can help ensure
that we have high
quality jobs for people
at all levels of
education and training.
Certainly important
that we really
help to improve
those low wage jobs
and provide career opportunities
for growth, and so on.
What else would you
say that young people
need to do to prepare for
the good jobs of the future?
Thinking about investments in
your own training and education
over the course of your
career is a really smart idea.
One of the things
people should be
doing is asking their employers
for what opportunities there
are for advancement,
asking your union
what can you do to help support
these kind of career ladders,
looking into things like joint
union and management programs
that support these
kind of career ladders.
For example, there's
programs that
will help people go from a
nursing assistant, to an LPN,
to a registered nurse.
And if you can
think of supporting
those kinds of
trajectories, you can really
carve out a career
that really let's
you punch the ticket
to the middle class.
I think that's good advice.
Young people have
lots of opportunities
and they have to
create new ones along
with the partnership of
the Department of Labor,
and good employers, and
good labor organizations.
So thank you very much.
It's been my pleasure.